senator Doug Jones is the first Democrat
elected to the Senate from Alabama in 25
years he defeated the GOP Roy Moore in a
special election last month Jones is a
member of the Homeland Security
Committee he's with us from Capitol Hill
for his first Network interview since
his swearing in earlier this month
senator Jones for we're very happy to
have you with us let me start with what
are your expectations for this speech
from the president tonight well first of
all let me thank you for having me this
morning I really appreciate it you know
I'm hoping and expecting that the
president will deliver a presidential
address not a campaign address but a
presidential address in which he lays
out not only his accomplishments this
past year but also his goals for the
future I hoping he is going to reach
across the aisle I think he's going to
be talking about unity I think that's
the best way to advance the agenda I
think my election was somewhat of a
wake-up call for America that we need to
to really get together to try to reach
across the aisle have a bipartisan
agreement on these things and get the
country moving yes your election was a
little dicey there senator Jones we're
very happy as as Norah and John said to
have you here what do you need to hear
from the president to unify the country
what exactly does he need to say well I
don't think he needs to just draw a line
in the dust and say it's my way or the
highway what I think he needs to do is
to try to lay out his goals lay out some
specifics of what he wants to do I think
there's a lot of areas both in
immigration as well as infrastructure
and some of the other things that the
president wants to move forward then I
think Democrats and Republicans alike
will embrace if the question is one
atone I think a tone is going to be very
important for him to try to reach out to
Democrats and Republicans alike
to try to make sure that we are working
together and this is not just a fight
it's just not a battle between one
faction or another but something that we
can do as Americans let me ask you then
about substance because the president is
expected to talk tonight about
immigration as well as infrastructure
and on the issue of immigration the
White House has proposed a generous
proposal in terms of a pathway to
citizenship for some almost 2 million
dreamers but at the same time wants a
lot of money 25 billion dollars for some
type of border security would you
support that
well I'm gonna look at that obviously
everyone was to increase security on the
Border's what that exactly looks like
and how much it's going to cost is going
to be the details that we really haven't
seen from the government at this point
you know it's twenty five billion
dollars is a lot of money during the
campaign the president talked about
building a wall but he said Mexico was
going to pay for well now we know it's
going to be the American public that's
going to pay for it so we have to be
careful we have to be smart with our
money but look I think that the
president has laid out goals and
objectives that need to be put on the
table and discussed I think the
Democrats are going to have that I think
other Republicans are gonna have
something I'm very optimistic about an
immigration plan going forward senator
would you give us your sense of your
party exactly on this question of
immigration you're making reasonable
sounding views here about listening to
what the president has to say there are
a lot of Senators in your party you
don't want to do a deal with this
president so can you straighten us out
here on exactly what the receptivity is
going to be to this offer from the
president sure I don't think it's a
question of doing a deal with this
president I don't think you're going to
see that at all I think they want to get
a immigration deal done obviously daca
and the dreamers are very very important
but border security is also important to
Democrats the details are going to be
something that have to be worked out we
have to look at what some people call
chain migration other people call family
reunification all of those is going to
be issues what I'm hoping we can do is
focus on the two most important pillars
of immigration right now which is the
daca issue as well as border security I
think there can be broad consensus on
those two pillars and you voted with the
Republicans for the spending deal
despite not having a deal on daca
how and why did you decide to vote
against your own party well I don't
think I've voted against my own party in
particular there were other Democrats
that voted like I did I had to do a
different equation you know I campaign a
lot on the child Health Insurance
Program chip that was an important part
of my campaign it's important to my
state where 150,000 kids were getting
pink slips for their health care that
was very important that we were funding
chip for six years
Alabama also would have been hurt a lot
by a shutdown in the government we have
a lot of federal dollars that come in so
I looked at the whole picture I was not
happy to be honest with you I don't
think
continuing resolutions are a way to fund
the government we need to get back to
some regular order when we do a budget
and have that but having said that I had
to make a decision and I felt like
keeping the government open and funding
chip was the right way to go all right
senator Jones the night of your election
you said this was a this was a
fulfillment of a lifelong dream you
still feel that sir absolutely it's just
amazing I've told folks that have walked
off that Senate floor as a Senate
staffer in 1980 with mobile boss Howell
Heflin and to come back with the Vice
President Biden and my old friend
trailing me vice president Mondale vice
president pence on the floor it was just
an amazing experience and I am honored
and humbled to be here all right a lot
of work to do Thank You senator Jones
really good to see you sir
thank you thank you any time thank you
and remember to watch CBS News coverage
of the State of the Union tonight
starting at 9:00 Eastern 8:00 central
right here on CBS John Gill and I will
report here from New York and Jeff Glor
will anchor in Washington our entire
political team will provide reporting
and analysis